effectivement c'est la tenue des ventes
dans le futur à la commanderie jobs
100-120 ils présentèrent et sans se
baser finalement sur le passé que je
vais partager avec vous aujourd'hui
c'est une somme d'expériences que j'ai
pu avoir
évidemment conclusion ils ont mené des
expériences qui sont ils de conseil sur
les discussions
je suis avoir écrit studio et docks
et dans cette ambiance enjouée
l'imposition dans les studios elle est
parfois un petit peu mais quand ça
tangue chavire speaker finalement plus
que jamais avec une pluie d expériences
qui peuvent être partagées mais cette
position basse de la bce vous inclure en
verre dans la présentation et dans ce
que j'ai pu devenir maman de sujets
aussi un entrepreneuriat que le reste a
dit dans sa ville elle nourrit donc
comment comment finalement le définir
heureux sans être en énorme équipe
plutôt d'associer mon billet je vais
finalement la milice en soi et c'est une
saine distance des résultats
et surtout finalement un point de vue
qui ne doit être objectif parce qu'il
est votre point de vue est donc
aujourd'hui cette définition là j'aurais
pu voilà vous présentez comme ça il est
né en en ballots vous demandez à chacun
d'entre vous qui aimez vous allez
sûrement vous présenter à des contres
non entrés aux autres fonctions
nouvelles nationalités van zon funky ou
détermine kivu près d 1 mondial souvent
le résultat de la naissance dans une
famille et de l'éducation nous espérons
voir et qui évidemment peuvent nous ne
castrés dans le passé notamment pourquoi
le personnel lorsque je me souviens en
fait de vivre en espérant se j'ai eu la
première si je m'appelle main par
définition
bamba dans notre société sas annulé
c'est un musulman est restée trois
choses le place déjà dans une catégorie
à laquelle je m'agace naturellement je
suis né également dans cet environnement
aujourd'hui l'ancien opposera la
question somalienne autres et avoir les
données en france est grand et en france
à ce sénégal se perdait
différentes choses il m'arrive parfois
de mettre en question cette année
vitesse devait revoir et c'est terrible
la partie cependant la question dérange
et finalement je me fixe des mariés qui
ne sont pas là et qui sont juste une
somme d'expériences comme aujourd'hui
qui est mort chanson n'est finalement
que le reflet du regard qu'on a le
regard des autres surya s'avère un
bambin entrepreneurs par les gens qui
sont ici ont différentes en vestiaires
les gones est entrepreneur ça va être un
homme à ma mère évidemment ce même balle
la vérité que j'ai vu le roi c'est de
prouver la place dans ces différents
environnements
comment l être en ce moment c'est
comment être sérieux en étant à la fois
détendu différentes avec des lances pour
venir à aucun sujet en fait et pourquoi
je pense une devront savoir pen qui nous
sommes et quel est le gros dans cette
société
je suis vraiment en revenir à des
notions à les notions assez
est-il vrai qu est ce qui me déplaît
comme je suis bon notamment les symboles
de caution c'est moi ou est ce moi
pendant ce mois c'est quoi en fait
est ce que ce mois c'est le regard des
gens qui le défient dans une posture où
et c'est finalement c'est juste des
envies que j'ai vu ce sont juste des
sentiments et les émotions qui peuvent
évidemment des danses a pas de base
assez difficile arrive je pense qu'on a
tous fait à l'époque et c'est heureux de
nous poser de savoir qui nous sommes
pourquoi parce qu'à partir du moment où
on simple quelles sont nos points
faibles son droit de prendre un
martèlement non ce n'est celle de santé
obsan en deux temps forts et on se peut
se dire oui effectivement le diplôme
c'est très
société et à quoi sert-il en angola
quel est le but des mesures internes je
pense qu'on arrive à des conclusions qui
deviennent beaucoup plus pratique et sur
lesquels nous nous orientons nos actions
de manière un peu plus président vers
nos objectifs
le présent pour moi ceci l'énergie le
futur en des exemples assez assez sain
et qui sont très qui sont les vrais sens
c'est un exemple retrouve parfois mais
qui grimpe à ses drops
c'est grâce à ces nouveaux agents du
travail de la nature de sa manière le
mariage global sa part des annonceurs et
sans même savoir ce qu'ils ont à vent
comme subsistance
pourtant la fin de journée salim entre
le ventre 20 ils travaillent le
lendemain de la manière dont on a
forcément pris d'aller faire une course
de l'ail haché les choses par contre par
les actions effectif
donc je vais te réveiller l'intérêt la
chasse dans tango qu'ils arrivent à
22h10 pas qu'ils veulent et je pense que
pour ma part moi à l'autre par ailleurs
de réunion sociale c'est quelque chose
qui me réussit plutôt et nadir répéter
certaines stations en attendant
convaincu
d'avoir des résultats qui sont possibles
sur ses actionnaires et donc cet exemple
éviter le moindre ennui sa salle jacques
brel assez bien la pensée qui est qui et
un manque d'eau semble dans ce sens être
humain vraiment selon le regard des gens
on se sent valorisé vraiment ce nombre
10 ans
aujourd'hui si j'ai eu l'honneur d'être
arrivé ici je pense que c'est c'est très
subjectif mais également c'est d'une
part de reiki sur internet sur lequel je
pense que ma place si drum qui a alerté
des organisateurs ou je pense que de
très peu de personnes en prospection et
du sein droit
mon présent ce qui nous revient ça des
arts ina totalement les futures
réalisations on est amené à mener
aidé en cela et dans la vie normale
je pense qu'il ya des choses qui ne
devraient pas être en conflit
c'est finalement l'être le fait
pour le reste tu veux si je devais vous
poser une question qui est vous je pense
que la plupart des femmes et c'est par
expérience ce registre la finalité
serait plus venant être et les autres
dans le faire je suis j'ai fait via la
fin plus dedans je suis également que
j'étais dans une autre manière lettres
lettres l'essence est l'homme que dans
l'action est là et n'ont finalement les
réussites nous nos statuts et sylvette
parfois ce qu'ils veulent pas rentrer
les rapports ou potentiels il étudié qui
dort en france chacun d'entre nous et je
pense que je pense plus que de souvenirs
de cette manière c'est finalement
inscrit encore une partie qu'on la
mendicité dynastique et riec qui en fait
partie
henning de la personne peu avant la fin
de la dynastie
du printemps donc tout ça pour dire au
bout du compte tout prouve nous il y à
un environnement qui veut être une
illusion par rapport à une impasse que
satan vernon hill il est juste un reflet
en date et la manière dont est perçue la
mer dans les calculs film pas si haut
débit finalement c'est notre état en
tant qu'humain et également nos
inspirations la valeur d'une somme de
choses qu'ils veulent qui pour ce seul
essai en résine et qu'il faut se les est
qu'il faut se les est libre en fête
en somme ce que j'essaye donné par là
évidemment vous est ce que au moins 100
selon les légendes et vous êtes sûr tout
ce que vous voulez pour qu'elles se
disent ah parce que c'est ce que je
manque c'est ce que j'ai envie je suis
de soi je suis une bonne heure je suis
je suis la déception parfois je suis
blonde soudan fait le délice et les gens
c'est les bras levés et le père de mon
fils et moi même et les peintres en
conflit avec la société
[Applaudissements]